che cos'è un tavolo mi spiego
avete mai pensato a quanti oggetti noi
abbiamo nella nostra vita che vediamo in
un modo solo e utilizziamo in un modo
solo mentre invece potrebbero avere
mille altri utilizzi per esempio appunto
un tavolo e quindi che cos'è un tavolo c
senz'altro è una cosa su cui appoggiamo
degli oggetti oppure potrebbe essere la
scrivania su cui lavoriamo tutti i
giorni quindi un tavolo è senz'altro uno
strumento però un tavolo è anche un
luogo il tavolo per esempio è il luogo
in cui si raduna la famiglia è il luogo
in cui si discute pensate alla tavola
rotonda di viale artù e luogo in cui
nascono gli amori talvolta si consumano
attorno a un tavolo
nascono le rivoluzioni quella francese
quella cubana o quella molto più
pacifica e gioiosa di slow food alla
quale ho la fortuna di partecipare io
cosa voglio fare oggi a proposito di
tavoli vi voglio raccontare la mia
storia legata ai tavoli e la mia storia
comincia quando io facevo il broker
io facevo il broker compravo i vendevo
azioni tutti i giorni tutti i santi
giorni per fare un profitto per qualcuno
in quel momento il mio tavolo era un
tavolo di quelli coi monitor sopra con i
numerini che lampeggiano con i grafici
che indicano andamento delle azioni
avevo tre telefoni che squillano in
continuazione e gente con
l'ansia del profitto addosso che mi
abbagliava ordini da trasmettere in
borsa
in quel periodo l'unica connessione che
io utilizzavo era quella con la borsa do
attraverso la quale comprava e vendeva
azioni è l'unica rete in cui vivevo era
quella che più o meno consciamente
imprigionava me e tutti coloro che
circondavano quel tavolo e un giorno era
un giorno particolarmente difficile
perché i numerini erano tutti rossi i
monitor vomitavano papato che
annunciavano l'imminente fine del mondo
tipo proprio moriremo tutti i grafici
andavano in picchiata verso il basso
rossi come sangue e i telefoni vi erano
veramente impazziti e io ero seduto a
quel tavolo io sono seduto a quel tavolo
e alza la testa alza la testa che cosa
vedo vedo una donna una donna che sa è
disperata la faccia triste
alla faccia triste e un sacco un sacco
di carta in mano è venuta a coprire le
perdite del marito in borsa io me la
ricordo bene quella faccia meglio
proprio l'immagine davanti a me di quel
momento questa donna con la sua
disperazione prende il sacco ne strappa
al bordo superiore e nel rovescia
letteralmente contenuto sul mio tavolo
erano mazzette di banconote da 100 mila
lire a cui tutto mi trovo con i monitor
che continuano annunciare la fine del
mondo i telefoni che urlano e questa
surreale montagna di banconote davanti a
me e io in quel momento capisco che c'è
qualcosa che non va c'è davvero qualcosa
che non mai che ho bisogno di prendere
una boccata d'aria di respirare e magari
perché no di berne un bicchiere di vino
per cui mi slancio la cravatta mi
allontano da quel tavolo ed esco
esco e mi dirigo verso un osteria in
cerca del mio bicchiere di vino e del
mio momento di riflessione arrivando
nell'osteria entro
e che cosa vedo un tavolo però a un
tavolo diverso da quello che ho appena
abbandonato era completamente diverso
innanzitutto sopra non aveva nulla che
urlava aveva un po di salame un po di
formaggio un fiasco di vino
attorno a questo tavolo c'erano delle
sedie e sopra le sedie c'erano delle
persone tra queste persone e rari e
evidente che ci fosse una connessione
una connessione forte basata sulla
condivisione sulla condivisione di
quello che c'era su quel tavolo e allora
io attratto istintivamente attratto
faccio per avvicinarmi e loro
guardandomi forse vedendo la cravatta
allentata la mia faccia spaventata non
lo so mi fanno cenno e mi chiamano mi
invitano a sedermi e sedendomi mi
accorgo che si sul tavolo c'erano il
vino c'è una sala a me c'era già nel
formaggio ma c'erano anche cose
infinitamente più leggere infinitamente
più importanti c'erano le idee
c'era una voglia di stare insieme
c'era una visione comune del mondo e una
voglia di stare insieme facendo delle
cose che poi venivano rimesse su quel
tavolo affinché tutti potessero
servirsene di nuovo ed è proprio quello
il momento in cui io servendomi per la
prima volta da quel tavolo che capisco
mi misero da quel tavolo è veramente o
un attimo di folgorazione
e cambiò completamente prospettiva
cambia completamente prospettiva per
esempio se fino a quel giorno qualcuno
mi diceva la parola inglese share
io cosa pensavo azioni compravendita il
profitto da quel momento invece ho
realizzato che la parola share
nella stessa lingua l'inglese vuol dire
condivisione vuol dire condividere
condividere fare insieme le cose da
quella visione comune del mondo quella
voglia di fare insieme le cose
cos'è che producono sì un valore ma chi
se ne frega a chi va a quel valore se
n'è per tutti quando c'è la condivisione
per cui è proprio in quel momento che io
decido di fare di quel contesto di
quella situazione di quella sensazione
un nuovo punto di partenza per me per la
mia vita e quindi eccomi qua oggi
davanti a voi a fare cosa
a far parte della rete di terra madre e
voi vi chiederete ma che cos'è la rete
di terra madre la rete di terra madre
sono persone sono persone in 170 paesi
del mondo che vivono distanti tra di
loro centinaia di migliaia di chilometri
hanno facce diverse hanno culture
diverse parlano lingue diverse e ognuna
tutti i giorni lavora chi nel proprio
campo per coltivare la propria terra chi
magari sulla sua barchetta sul lago
vittoria o che so io nell'oceano
pacifico per pescare kiko i propri
animali sugli al peggio nelle stalle
prendendosene cura chi nelle cucine
preparando amorevolmente il cibo che
servirà ai propri clienti o chi ancora
nell'università coltiva davvero il
futuro e la cosa straordinaria che
queste persone così lontane tra di loro
apparentemente sono incredibilmente
connesse e unite perché loro che cosa
fanno
sono tutte sedute attorno a questo
tavolo più o meno virtuale talvolta di
più talvolta meno che terra madre che la
rete di terra madre e che cosa fanno
attorno a quel tavolo condividono e
condividono che cosa senz'altro i
problemi certo le preoccupazioni le
angosce ma soprattutto condividono le
idee le soluzioni insieme risolvono
hanno imparato vivendo lo che insieme si
risolvono i problemi si risolvono i
problemi i propri problemi certo ma si
risolvono i problemi gli uni degli altri
insieme e condividendo per cui il
messaggio che io vi voglio lasciare oggi
è questo ma perché non lo facciamo noi
tutti i santi giorni
noi abbiamo la cultura abbiamo gli
strumenti abbiamo la rete
abbiamo tutto che cosa ci manca perché
non lo facciamo
ebbene secondo me ci manca una cosa ci
manca una consapevolezza che la
consapevolezza che quella voglia di
stare insieme quella voglia di stare
insieme gioiosamente può diventare
qualcosa di diverso può diventare una
voglia di essere insieme essere insieme
qualcosa di diverso dal nostro sé
qualcosa di infinitamente più grande del
nostro se essere un'opportunità
un'opportunità per noi stessi per la
comunità in cui viviamo e per il resto
del mondo